[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
happy wednesday everyone emily's back
we got rick harrison from palm stop pawn
stars um
palm stars
tom stars is something more perverted
and of course cat and tyrus are here as
well
but also joining us tonight
the 45th president donald j trump
industries in conjunction with regular
bed rest and plenty of fresh vegetables
presents the meeting of the mines part
one
[Music]
that's right our first ever one-on-one
sit down with the man himself
okay he sat and i stood but you could
you can hardly tell the difference
it's true i headed down to bedminster
new jersey to interview the former
president and our conversations covered
many topics from afghanistan to the
economy but mostly we focused on me
and how i'm making late night tv great
again
yes
but the interview spanned far and wide
and much like kat applying her hair
extensions
i want to use every single piece of it
but first
[Music]
greg seven jobs
seven
seven jokes according to new research
cannabis use has doubled the risk of
heart attacks in young people
when willie nelson was told this he said
i'll be 89 next april jackass
american crime story produced by monica
lewinsky airs on fx this week which i
guess answers the age-old question who
do i have to sleep with to get my
project on tv
yes 23 years after their affair lewinsky
says she's still waiting for an apology
from bill clinton
the difference is bill clinton is 75 now
and these days he honestly can't
remember if he had sex with that woman
or not
so 911 mastermind khalid sheikh mohammed
has been behind bars at guantanamo for
over 20 years and still doesn't have a
trial date the good news is prison
officials have finally approved his
request for a sex change
that would happen
on a similar note uh some of the afghan
women considered attacking their new
taliban government with car bombs but
then they remembered that none of them
are allowed to drive
somber
truthful
late night host jimmy kimmel is back on
the air after taking the summer off he's
missed a lot
kimmel says if you're not vaccinated you
shouldn't get a hospital icu bed but i'm
not sure if jimmy was being sincere
because he wasn't crying
anyway it's just funny hearing someone
say i see you
who nobody actually sees
look
i don't want to suggest that kimmel's
show has become boring and predictable
but last night during the taping people
in the studio audience were changing the
channel
and that's your seven jokes
all right
and now part one with donald trump
great to see you mr president thank you
very much greg thank you for having me
uh the most important question i have to
ask you is how about my ratings your
ratings are fabulous i just saw you're
now the king of late night yes
i mean you're beating some very
untalented people to be honest with you
so i'm not so sure how great that is but
they are so bad and it's about time
somebody came in and you're really
beating a badly great i feel kind of
guilty about it because i feel like i'm
beating up unarmed people well they're
not very talented you are so
congratulations i'm mildly talented
they're just untalented well and you're
very different yes i am very different
speaking of do you remember how much i
hated you for that period of time there
was a period of time when you weren't a
fan and then you started noticing that
things were getting done and you said
you know i may not like them but look we
have a good economy we have good
military we have good everything right
and then you started and now i think i
don't know if it's love but it's getting
close and we like it it's not i wouldn't
say it's love but i would say it's
admiration
and also admitting that i was wrong
because i was focusing on words and not
deeds and now we're at a time where okay
there are no more mean tweets and we
have a really nice president and the
country is in the crapper so who would
you rather have well i don't know that
he's a nice president
i'm not sure about that but i can tell
you the country has never been more
unsafe we have people pouring in through
our southern border which
everyone's forgetting about right now
because of the travesty of afghanistan
and if you look at the people coming in
by the hundreds by the thousands and
these are not the people necessarily
that wanted the protection right these
are people so are they terrorists how
many terrorists are coming in and they
were aggressive very aggressive at the
plane and they pushed their ways uh you
know their way onto the plane why do you
think that democrats have such a problem
with like uh incentive
incentivization like they
if you if you introduce friction on the
border you reduce immigration they don't
understand that what is what is the
problem with that how can they not
cannot see that i really believe it's
gross incompetence
and the only thing good for them about
afghanistan is it makes what they're
doing on the border look good because
that was the dumbest thing i've ever
seen yeah we don't want a wall we don't
want this we'll just let people come
through it's a disaster the borders it
was the safest border we've ever had and
now it's the worst what unites all of
them is a lack of process they have they
do not understand process we just want
order i want people to come into our
country but i want to i want to line and
negate people that can walk through and
legally and legally legally vetted
strongly vetted yeah but when you think
that they move the military out first
think of this because we had a great
plan you know even biden i think he made
a mistake when they did it they were all
screaming at him but when he said that
since
president trump where he calls it the
past administration
signed the deal not one soldier was shot
at or killed think of that you know why
because they knew the consequences and
our conditions were tough
and then they came in and they just
moved out who would move out the
military first the military goes last
and safely
and sadly those 13 great soldiers and
200 people you know 200 people more than
200 people were killed and a lot of
people are badly injured
really badly injured
it wouldn't have happened do you think
it is better
to
to be feared right and that that's the
difference they don't fear our president
well i don't know if he just doesn't
seem like they know what they're doing
right yeah that's not a question i don't
even think it's a question of fear it's
a question of respect and it's a
question of being smart
when you hear i could just say because i
dealt with abdul right let's call him
abdul but that's the man yes and he's
now the head of the taliban and he was
the head of the taliban when i dealt
with him
and i started it off very tough because
you know you're going to pay tremendous
consequences i don't have to go the
level of toughness but it was bad
and they understood what i said and
there was no way they were going to do
anything to us we could have taken our
time we could have taken a year two
years
but to leave 85 billion dollars worth of
equipment for them to fly around apache
helicopters so this is the greatest war
machine outside of the submarine this is
the greatest war machine there is the
apache right they're very very you know
tens of millions of dollars they have 28
of them yes that's more than any other
country in the world has except for us i
can't even get a gun in new york yeah if
i joined the taliban i could have gotten
a helicopter no problem yes in fact i
saw that the other day
we can't have guns but the taliban they
can have 27 each i could have a
helicopter that would get me to the
hamptons and back right yeah that's
right
all right
i thought that that's only part one
that's only part but for for more let's
get immediate feedback from the media on
that amazing part one interview
jean nelson reports with gene nelson
mr gutfeld first off i mean i just have
to say that was probably the hardest
hitting interview of a president i have
ever seen thanks for that what's your
name uh gene well jim you know it was
really a lot of fun i learned a lot but
it's only part one
i have four more parts of that interview
to go hard to believe it gets any better
because what i saw took no prisoner yes
it did take no prisoners and it also
looks like it might have captured your
heart
it did
[Music]
i uh i live right around the corner if
you uh
why did you say so in the first place
oh drink of water
[Applause]
[Laughter]
he just offered tyrus five bucks for the
wrestling belt backstage host upon stars
rick harrison
her mouth can run faster than the
criminals she used to defend in court
hosts of outnumbered emily compagno
byob fox news contributor cat tim
and he has his own parking space at the
big and tall men's shop my massive
sidekick and the nwa's world television
champion tyrants
so rick welcome to the show
i mean i mean how do i follow up that
interview
which one
probably the second one yeah
the look on your face was you were very
disturbed and full of regret and i had a
tear in my eye it's all the same time
man yes
one of the things you notice though
trump is always entertaining no matter
what
i mean yeah i mean like it was fun when
he was president it really was i mean
i mean with biden you just know for a
fact that he's going to say something
really weird at a press conference and
everyone's going to talk about it it's
the same thing everything trump
he talks about every taliban gets 27
guns yes
and you know what that's directionally
true it probably does come out to about
27 guns you know yeah i bet you know god
you should go there pawns pawn starts
i'm cool i'm cool
think of it uh i'll give you uh can you
make you because they'll all be in lines
with the same guns and none of the guns
work all the taliban will be trying to
give you guns so they could buy opium oh
no no no the whole market's flooded with
these things
all right tyrus uh i know you had some
thoughts about the interview have your
thoughts changed you know what man i'm
i'm normally would never do this man but
wow man that was
that was a written one
no but it was
it was a conversation and you didn't
change
no
people when they interview president
change you didn't kiss his ass no and i
applaud you and you got a great you had
a conversation you even told him i
didn't like because i used to hear him
going this guy this guy here you can and
that was that was a great conversation
the residual effect and i'm not talking
about that second thing i don't even
know what that was
but i'm proud of you both coming out
tonight nice job
weren't you
but all when all around the world right
now you are hearing
jim acosta and brian selter dancing in
the streets we're back we have something
to talk about for the next six months we
got a new book deal you have brought him
back
in a way that
cnn's excited you know that you did a
great job and now they're going to
roast you for it and go after you
forever and i say bring it on i want to
be roasting
emily
emily good to see your uh got your real
estate license
my theme was presidential obviously
well you're uh you're like you're like a
hot topic uh real estate
agent
anyway i'll take it out you're a goth
you sell gothic houses
anyway anyway
thoughts
cares i just kept thinking i missed that
guy like you know two minutes of the two
of you and the banter and getting to the
heart of the issue as well like yeah you
know what
the president we have in the white house
right now he's doing a horrible job and
he's not nice everything that we've been
told is actually a lie right and because
of it
13 service members are died americans
are stranded we've surrendered after a
20-year war we've lost 83 billion worth
of equipment and the future is probably
more bleak than it's ever been for those
who remain there including our allies
he goes he cuts to the heart of the
issue and abdul now in power uh i just i
love that he always leaves us with these
concise points and um stuff to talk
about for a long time yeah it's weird
cat cause some of the stuff when you
read it it doesn't sound funny until it
comes out of his mouth
yeah
i mean i was reading it and i thought it
sounded funny because i could imagine it
coming out of his mouth and i agree with
what tyra said you didn't really you
were very yourself you know like the
first thing you brought up was tell me
how great i am
which is exactly what it's like to be
around you all the time
um but yeah it was it's
true congratulations on your ratings
[Laughter]
oh yeah greg
you did it
you did it greg did all your good alone
you threw the show on your back and you
by yourself with no help from anyone
and the fact that that interview was in
new jersey that's what a 15-minute ride
i had some questions
you know what i feel like i feel like
peter brady being ganged up on by greg
and marsha because i
i lied about something no i thought that
it was it was you know it was great it
was it was kind of fun even when you
were talking about certainly some
serious things
it was still fun yeah so you know good
for you thank you good for all of us
good for all of you no no no no no no no
no no no it's all you i'm like oh you
that would have been the first time
you've ever said that yeah you're not
wasting that tonight no yeah i'm gonna
save yeah you're gonna waste that till
you really need something i prefer i
prefer it when you guys talk behind my
back not in my face when have i ever
done that
we talk about them on the podcast
that doesn't count all right we got to
move on part two of our interview later
in the show it gets even better hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else